ونحييكم من جديد الى موضوعنا الثاني صوره
رماديه في السودان الذي يصارع ايام الحرب
بصعوبه اشتباكات لا تهدا واوضع هنا ثانيه
تزداد سوءا يوما بعد يوم تزايدت معها
المخاوف من السقوط في عذابات الحصار
الكامل في الخرطوم وفقع ما نقلت وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه فبينما تشتد حدث
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
يعاني المدنيون من التداعيات فاكثر من نصف
عدد سكان السودان بحاجه الى المساعده
والحمايه وفق الامم المتحده سكان العاصمه
الخرطوم والبالغه عددهم نحو خمسه ملايين
يواجهون تراجعا حاديا في الخدمات الطبيه
وفي الحصول على المواد الغذائيه فضلا عن
انقطاع الكهرباء والماء كذلك شح الامدادات
في المتاجر والصيدليات حيث تعاني جماعه
الاغاثه من اجل تقديم مساعده واسعه للسكان
صاحب ذلك التساع عمليه السرقه والنهب كذلك
والتي
[موسيقى]
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من لندن انه
عمران عبد الله حسن عضو المكتب الاستشاري
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بك من رياض
الصحفي السوداني فتح الرحمن يوسف اهلا بك
ومن واشنطن فاطمه غزاليه صحفيه الناشطه في
قضايا المراه اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام
واسمحوا لي قبل مناقشه هذه التفاصيل وما
ورد كذلك من اخبار ان نقف على الصوره
الدقيقه لما يحدث في خصوص الملف الانساني
معك استاذه فاطمه استاذه فاطمه البعض يقول
يجب علينا ان ندق ناقوس الخطر اكثر من مره
لان الوضع في السودان اصبح تقريبا شبه
كارثي وهناك مخاوف حتى تتعلق بامن المراه
وبحياتها ما ابرز ما وصلك من تفاصيل يخص
هذا الملف
اه شكرا لك شكرا قناه العربيه
تحيه لي ايضا مشاهديكي الرحمه لكل الشهداء
وعادل الشفاء للجرحى وعودا امنا
للمفقودين وللوطن في حوضنا السلام ان شاء
الله نعم يعني الحديث عن يعني ما يتعلق
بالمراه والانتهاكات التي يعني تتعرض لها
المراه السودانيه والفتيات السودانيات
وحتى السقيرات من عنف يشير الى خطوره يعني
تدحرج هذه الحرب الى يعني الى القاع خاصه
الحديث عن الاقتصابات
هنالك يعني عدد من
حوادث الاقتصابات في السودان تحديدا في
الخرطوم ودارفور المناطق المحروبه والتي
تشهد معارك محتدمه في هذه في هذه الاثناء
ايضا هنالك معارك ايضا
المؤسف ان هذه الاعتداءات الجنسيه خاصه
منها الاقتصابات نسبه التبليغ عنها يعني
لن تكون كبيره ولم تكن كبيره لان هنالك
وصمه
الاغتصاب نفسها لذلك الارقام التي نسمع
عنها ويتحدث الحوادث التي يتحدث عنها
الناس والمراكز والاطباء لا لا تكشف ولا
توضح ارقام هذه يعني الارقام لا زالت ليس
دقيقه ولكن هل وصلك مثلا لانه هناك
مراقبين يتحدثون عن عناصر تتبع لقوات
الدعم السريع هناك اخرون يتحدثون عن من
يدعم او عناصر تتبع للجيش السوداني هل
هناك توضيح بخصوص هذا الموضوع وصلك او
بلاغك
حتى الان كما تعلمين الصوره خاتمه وكل ما
يدور في هذه الحرب مجرد اتهامات للبعض
يعني الدعم يتهم الدعم السريعي يتهم
القوات المسلحه المسلحه القوات المسلحه
ايضا تتهم الجيش ولكن ليس قريب على يعني
ازمه الاغتصاب او قضيه الاغتصاب او حوادث
الاغتصابات سواء كانت من القوات المسلحه
صحيح ساعود لك يا استاذه فاطمه نحن نتحدث
عن الاغتصار نتحدث عن القتل المتعمد نتحدث
بدرجه اقل خطوره عن النهب والسرقه
وخليني افهم من ضيوفي كذلك ما الوضع الذي
وصل اليه السودان اليوم سابدا معك استاذ
عمران من لندن استاذ عمران البعض يقول بان
الطرفين يتحملان مسؤوليه تجاهل معاناه
المدنيين في داخل السوداني هل الدعم
السريع واعي بخطوره ما يحدث
[موسيقى]
حقيقه يعني الوضع كما اسلكتي وكما اسلفت
ضيفتك فاطمه غزالي الوضع في السودان وضع
كارثي ووضع يعني لا يستطيع ان يتصوره
الانسان وضع الانسان مهم يعني الان الوضع
المعيشه سيء جدا جدا
هذا استاذ عمران على فكره هذا ندركه جميعا
ولكن تصريحات حضرتك وتسريحات كذلك التي
نقراها عن الجيش تضعنا امام مشهد سريع
ليفوق كل
مخيلتنا او المنطق لانه تصريحات تجتمع على
انه يجب ايجاد حلول ولكن ليست هناك حلول
هناك تمسك باستخدام لغه السلاح هل يتحمل
الدعم السريع ذلك
نحن منذ بدايه الحرب
ومتابعينا
لتصريحات السيد القائد الاعلى للقوات
الدعم السريع وكل المستشارين والناطقين
الرسميين باسم الدعم السريع ينادون في
الميناء من اليوم الاول ان تكون هنالك
هدنه ان يكون هنالك تفاوتا يجب ان يوقف
اطلاق النار يجب ان يوقف النزيف الدماء
لانه الوضع الانساني فوق حاجاتنا الشخصيه
والتصوراتنا ورغباتنا فبالتالي نحن يعني
من اليوم الاول طالبنا بهذا الامر لكن
سيده الفاضله الطرف الثاني الذي يتمثل في
الجيش ومن معه هو الذين يعني
يشعرون هذه النار وهم الذين يعني قد
يستفيدون من وراءها حقيقه نحن نحن
السيد فتح الرحمن سيد فتحي رحمن هل جيش
يتحمل مسؤوليه هذه الدرجه من معاناه
السودانيين ضيف يقول لك بانه الدعم السريع
كان موجود وهو الذي تابع محاولات ان يكون
هناك حوار ولكن التمسك بالارض ومحاوله
الكسب الجيش
وضعه كاولويه قبل حتى الملف الانساني في
داخل السوداني ما ردك
طيب شكرا جزيلا التحيه والتحيه لضيوفك
الكرام حقيقه للاسف الشديد هذه التصريحات
التي ادلى بها كلا المشاركين من لندن
للاسف الشديد لم تكن دقيقه ولن تكون يعني
ولم تكن يعني ذات التوصيفه
العادل للاسف الشديد اما لا لا يعني انا
تجاوزت
اخونا عمران باعتبار انه هو اصلا قوات دعم
سريع
ومضيت الى اختنا فاطمه بالله عليك يا
فاطمه كيف يعني تضعين
تتكلم كلامي عن انتهاكات معروفه لارضاء
العام والشعب السوداني انه انتهاكات تقوم
بها قوات الدعميه ولكن فقط
يوسف فقط اسمح لي لماذا اللوم تواجهه لصيد
فاطمه لم تؤشر ايه جهه لقالت
الجيش هي قالت ما يصلني
في المجمل نعم انا اوجه لامي الى الاخت
فاطمه لانها ليست من جزء من قوات الدعم
السريع بالتالي انا يعني كنت اتوقع ان
تتوقع الدقه والتوصيف يكون دقيق او يكون
على الاقل موزون يعني هي كونها تتكلم بشكل
عام هناك هناك اتهاقات وهناك اغتصاب يقوم
بها بعض الجيش وبعض الدعم السريع يعني
ممكن يقولوا عمران لانه عمران هو اصلا
للاسف الشديد منذ ولكن استاذ يوسف استاذ
استاذ يوسف استاذ يوسف لم افهم حضرتك
الحقيقه استاذ يوسف اسمح لي اسمح لي فقط
لم افهم حضرتك هي تحدثت ولا ادافع عنها
ولكن هناك من يتابعنا هي تحدثت عن
انتهاكات بالجمله يتحمل الك مسؤوليتها
وقالت بان هناك تقارير تردنا ولا اتهم لا
الطرف الاول ولا الطرف الثاني ولكن تتوجه
لها ولا تريد التوجه للاستاذ عمران وهو
كان صريح في اتهامكم انتم او في اتهام
الجيش على الاقل بتورطه في هذه الانتهاكات
توجه له وبالكلام هو كان واضح كان صريح
ذكركم نعم ارى انا ساقطع على التوجيه
المباشر يا اخونا عمران هو جزء من قوات
الدعم السريع ولكن انا يعني حاولت اتحدث
اود هذا اللوم لاخوتنا فاطمه لان هي ليست
الدعم السريعه وبالتالي ليس هناك اشكاليه
فانتحدث بصدق
وتتكلمنا هذه النقطه نتكلم لما ورد من
تصريحات من الاستاذ عمران تفضل
الاستاذ عمران يتحدث عن انه يعني كان قوات
الدعم السريع ملائكه نزلت من السماء
لانزال السكينه والتمارين على الشعب
السوداني وهي التي الان ومنذ ان وطئت
الخرطوم وحتى الان تعوس فسادا في الارض
تقتل العلماء تشرط الناس تقتحم البيوت
تكسر الممتلكات البنت تحتيه يعني في اي
زقاقه يعني تمارس كل ما يمكن ان يوصفه
بانها جرائم حرب من الدرجه الاولى وهذه
يعني ليست فريريه هذه حقيقه وكل الشعب
السوداني الان يعلمها وهناك يعني اجسام
الان تتحدث ولكن بعض الناس يتحدثوا لان
يعني يتحدث بشكل من الخفيه خوفا من
الملاحقه وخوفه من المواجهه
وان قلنا هناك مصالح مشتركه يعني تمنعه من
الحديث علانيه وصراحه ولكن نحن جزء من هذا
الشعب المكلوم نحن مستقلين لا ننتمي الى
اي جهه لجيش والاغوات دعم سريع ولا حزب
ولا حكومه ولا اي يعني جهه ايدولوجيه نحن
نتحدث هنا كصحفي كضمير الشعب السوداني
للاسف الشديد الذي يمارسه قوات النحل
السريعه
صحيح العالم صحيح العهد العصر هذا العصر
الحديث استاذ يوسف ولكن حضرتك تدعم وجهه
نظر معينه استاذ عمران تعليقك
طيب اول حاجه السيد يوسف وغيره من الذين
يتحدثون باسم الجيش او نيابه عنهم يدعون
عنهم محايدين لكن العكس تماما كل هذه
هؤلاء المتحدثين للاسف انا لا ادري حتى
يريدون كل الشعب السوداني ان يكون في صفهم
انا لا ادري ولماذا هذا ليس دعم سليم من
الابناء جلده هذا الشعب السوداني حتى
هاجمت للاستاذه فاطمه وتهاجمونه كل من
يعني يت
فوه
الشيء الثاني يا اخي انت تتحدث عن عن
الدعم السريع ناهيك عن الدعم السريع قبل
ان يكون قبل هذه المعركه من الذي يرتكب
الجرائم في في السودان حتى في الخرطوم منذ
2013 الثورات التي تقوم في في الخرطوم ولا
الذي يقع معها حالات الاقتصاد الاقتصابات
كانت متواجده تسعه طويله من الذي يفكها
عندما يريد ويمسكها عندما يريد من الذي
قتل المواطنين بالطيران في دارفور من الذي
قتلهم بالطيران في جبال النوبه من الذي
قتله في جنوب السودان اليس هذا الجيش الذي
تتدافع عنه انت الان الجيش هم ملائكه انت
تتحدث عنهم يا اخي حتى هذه الان الان الان
انتم موجهين قمتم بحمله داعيه كبيره جدا
جدا وتريدون ان تشيكن وتعيبوا الدعم
السريع وهنالك رده عده مسرحيات تدار في
الخرطوم ونحن نعلمها جيدا التنظيم
والتنظيم المؤتمر الوطني والذين معه يؤمن
هما اذكياء في هذا المجال والشعب السوداني
يعلم ذلك جيدا حتى هذه الصور وحتى هذه
الفيديوهات التي تخرجنا هي ليست
ولكن
برغم من كل ذلك وهنا سؤال حضرتك سيد يوسف
مهما كانت الخلافات والاختلافات وهي عميقه
جدا ولكن لماذا لا يتم طرح كل ذلك حول
طائله طاوله مستديره ويتم تغليب مصلحه
السوداني تغليب الملف الانساني على كل هذه
الخلافات والاختلافات التي تضطر الى
استخدام لغه الرصاص
طيب شكرا جزيلا لو سمحت قليلا على اخي
عمران يعني هو يتحدث بل الذي ارتكب
الانتهاكات الذي ارتكب الانتحاكات
والاعتصام في الخرطان عن ضحايا الثوره نعم
ضحايا الثوره وليس ضحايا الحرب الان هناك
اختلاف شاسع يعني
الثوره هم جزء اصيل من القوات الدعم
السريع هي التي قتلت المتظاهرين والثورين
ويعني عمله العمايل وهذا شيء معروف من
الذي قتل اهل دارفور يا رجل لما كنتم في
في شكل
وقام بالعباده وقاموا بالاختصابات
الاستاذ يوسف تعلم حضرتك بانو فيما بعد في
مرحله مراحل اتفقت طرفين
اعتقد بان كل الاطراف تجاوزت هذه المرحله
جلست على طويله واحده طبعا الجيش ودعم
السريع وكانت هناك اتفاقات ولكن توقفت مع
اطلاق اول الرصاصه السؤال المطروح هو
لماذا لا يتم تغليف مصلحه السوداني المدني
الذي لا يطلب العيش على مصلحه الحسابات
العسكريه هل يتحمل الجيش مسؤوليه ذلك سيد
يوسف
طيب شكرا جزيلا على هذا السؤال سؤال مهم
جدا جدا ودعيني لو سمحتي ادخل في الاجابه
بالشكر الجزيل لاخونا الدكتور علي التاج
وهو احد الذين يعملون بصمت ضمن مجموعه
كبيره تسمى بالعاليه الوطنيه للتحول
الديمقراطي والتحول المدني وهم كتله كبيره
من العلماء والسفراء
والسياسيين انقياء اتقياء يعني ناس بعيدين
عن الفساد الفساد الاداري الفساد المالي
الفساد ايا كان نوعه هؤلاء من الداخل
والخارج يقومون حلف كبير جدا وهما الان في
خضم هذه المفاوضات التي تتم بين القوات
الدعم السريع وقواتها الجيش السوداني وهم
يحاولوا يعملوا تقريب وجهات النظر ما بين
الالات
اذكر بانه في مرحله من مراحل رغم الدعم
الامريكي والسعودي انسحب من هالجيش الجيش
سحب من انسحب لانه لان قوات الدعم السريع
لم تستجب للشروط لم تستجد خلال
المستشفيات
الجامعات لم تقف يدها عن قتل العلماء في
الشارع
نعم انا اكون صريح معك جديد واكون صريح مع
كل الشعب السوداني المتابعه الان نعم
صراحه الان المعركه التي تدور في الخرطوم
يدور
باسم مجديرها تنظيم السابق لذلك التنظيم
السرقه ليس حريص على الاطلاق تكون هنالك
هدنه او يكون هنالك تفوق لان فرصه بقائه
ان يكون هنالك حرب وان يكون هنالك حرب
اهليه وان ينتهي الدعم السريع وينتهي كل
من ينادي بالديمقراطيه وبالتالي سيكون له
موجود هذا وايس في اي حال قبل اي شيء الا
هم مصيرهم سيكون السجون فبالتالي يراهنون
على استمرار هذه الحرب واستمرار هذه
المعاناه وهم يعرفون لا عند ليست لهم حدود
في الاخلاق ليس لهم حدود خطوط حمراء ممكن
بمبدا الغايه
يجب ان تكمله ولكن في حلقه اخرى انتهى
تماما التوقيت ساعتذر فاطمه لضيق الوقت
سنعود لكن مع الملف الانساني في حلقات
اخرى شكرا لضيوف من لندن عمرا عبد الله
حسن ومن الرياض فتح الرحمن يوسف شكرا لكم
السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات